Comic Con Africa is a place to see your
superheroes familiar characters and a
few villains some of the fans come
dressed in elaborate costumes
enthusiasts like Tanya Fury this costume
is from a Spanish folklore called la la
Lorna and it's a woman who haunts small
children it's a wives tale that they
tell so that no children walk away from
their parents and they'd be too scared
to see me if they did local creatives
known as the afro geek Community are
exhibiting here for the first time
showcasing locally produced content by
Africans we're at super team 4 which is
the first animated African Netflix so we
release here in the genre start to come
up and become more popular and Africa is
actually getting an opportunity to tell
their own stories within that rather
than us just consuming
from Japan from the US from the UK
also here for the first time is otaku
Town an area focusing on anime manga and
Japanese culture has been so much demand
for Japanese culture Japanese Goods
Japanese language Japanese everything
that essentially over the years people
kept asking for it and this year they
finally established it it's the ultimate
for all Japan lovers this is the place
to be the festival is a platform for
both local and international
entertainment and pop culture including
some of the world's biggest from the
worlds of film gaming comics and
collectibles there's a little bit of
everything for everyone you find
to say this the judgment-free Zone where
you can be anyone you want to be some
people become totally immersed in the
competitive but fun world of Gaming
others just taking the atmosphere
interacting with characters from their
favorite movies comic books and games
it's a chance for many to escape the
real world and enter a realm where geek
is Chic and nerd is the word
haramutasa Al Jazeera Johannesburg
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera